ken paxton texas attorney general
traveled with president trump to the
border yesterday and is now in the
faulkner focus great to see you attorney
general
let's begin by just looking at the stark
difference between
kamala harris as vice president at the
border in el paso texas
last week the former president donald
trump at the border
this week
so if you're asking for the comparison
it's really it really is amazing the
difference
of going to el paso and going to a place
where
things are actually happening where
we're actually having issues
um the president came to the place where
the action is happening where the
illegal crossings are occurring
and where border border patrol our
sheriffs our local law enforcement are
having to deal with real issues
i'm not just human trafficking and
people coming across the border but also
all types of crimes including the
the drugs coming across in large measure
you know you're having to deal with the
repercussions of changing policy i mean
it does come down to legalities when
you're talking about a title 42
and and how you handle people who come
into your state of texas
when the president says it would have
been better had
biden just gone to the beach and done
nothing what is he talking about in
terms of how things really have changed
well as a border state he the
president's exactly right we
if if if biden would have just left
things the way they were the way they
were under the trump administration
where catch and release was no longer
happening where the border patrol
were allowed to do their job where you
didn't have a president inviting people
to come across and saying hey we're not
going to deport you
and then eliminating the stay in mexico
program and then eliminating the
building the wall that's a lot of stuff
that was working so if biden would have
he's right if he would have just gone to
the beach and done nothing
we would still have we would still be
progressing towards
better border security instead of
undoing all the good that happened under
the trump administration you know i want
to get into
just a little bit about how the messages
are different too because when
the vice president kamala harris went
down to the northern triangle she
visited guatemala
and mexico she she said don't come
do not come and then her message flipped
she flip-flopped on that
and went back to more of a biden policy
which is more open door
how does that differ to what former
president trump says we
have to do right now so i mean
this started day one with the bite
administration he literally invited
people to come
and they they they obliged and the
numbers show it the facts show it
all the numbers from the trump
administration the improvement the
massive improvement from
the biden administration to the trump
administration and now this falling off
that happened
really fast like just look at the
numbers from a year ago to now all of
them whether it's crime whether it's
drugs
whether it's illegal immigration it's
all changed in a very dramatic way the
president is right
and i i love the comment about him being
called the actual borders are
yeah you know one of the numbers that
we're hearing about this week that are
just dark in some areas the amount of
fentanyl
coming in across the border has risen by
four thousand percent
that comes with crime that comes with a
whole lot going on in this country i
mean this is a wave now
uh that will take years potentially to
undo if they don't start moving quickly
a texas democrat
philemon vela says quote let's make one
thing clear
the narrative of a violent and insecure
border region is blatantly false
the border is not a war zone and the
wall abbott and trump are trying to get
texans
to pay for is not only a waste of their
hard-earned money
but also an un-american symbol of hatred
attorney general paxton what's your
reaction to that
my reaction is very simple if you talk
to the people that are dealing with this
every day border patrol agents
they like the wall the wall was built
the way they wanted it built trump took
their advice
he went to the people that were dealing
with this as professionals not as
politicians
but as professionals following federal
law and so
the border patrol agents who actually do
this every day
would disagree if they had the chance to
be honest because i've talked to them
i know the president has talked to him i
know the governor's talked to him they
would disagree
completely with those statements by that
democratic congressman you know i caught
the way you put that and you choose your
words very carefully i know
uh if they had the chance to be honest
how are politics at play here there's no
doubt that they are they are encouraged
not to talk
and i know that because i have talked
and i talked to them during the
obama administration and i knew they
weren't supposed to talk then and then
under the trump administration they were
allowed to talk and now they're back to
not being allowed to really say honestly
what they think
and i understand that they lose their
jobs if they if they do and so
there's definitely an attempt here to
keep transparency away from the american
people about what's
actually happening from the people who
know best
well look now what's very transparent is
what you and the governor of texas are
having to do
to deal with this and south dakota
governor christie nome is one of those
who answered the call coming from texas
loud and clear from the governor
she is sending national guard troops to
the border to help out here's what she
said today let's watch typically
securing the border would be the
responsibility of
the federal government but our federal
government is not doing their job the
governors of texas and arizona have
asked us for help
and this is a mission that national
guard is trained and equipped and does
with excellence so
when they made the request to me i
started running the protocols
asking if we had volunteers in my
national guard that would want to do
this mission
and had more than more than i could
possibly
anticipate attorney general paxton this
is not a good look for the biden
administration i mean it would seem
that governors in the in the great
states
across america are willing to do more
than the actual federal government to
help out the state of texas
am i getting that right god bless
christy noam god bless rhonda sanchez
god bless some of my friends
i have attorney general friends uh like
todd rokita in indiana who want to come
who are trying to figure out how to help
us because they realize that we have a
severe problem that isn't going to just
affect us this fentanyl problem
doesn't just stay in texas the smuggling
of human beings and human trafficking
doesn't just stay in texas
yeah i think it's it's a very sad
commentary that the biden administration
will not help us and just the opposite
they're doing just the opposite of what
needs to be
be done to help us they're hurting us
well and
from what you've been sharing and what
we know from other leaders is that
the american people unless they see
coverage
of a former president whose policies
were flipped unless we have these kinds
of conversations
and i have them with democrats too
they're not going to know just how bad
it is from this
administration we started with kamala
harris
and where she went your last quick
thoughts my last quick thought says
thank you president trump for coming to
the border
it brought attention to a a very massive
problem along our border
that will not just stay in texas it will
not just stay in arizona
it will affect the entire country and
it's going to be very costly from book
an
economic standpoint and a social
standpoint so
i really appreciate that he came i
appreciate that the governor put this
together governor abbott
it was a success in highlighting the
problem at the border
yeah you know i've had representatives
in the house gop
tell me that they were not invited to be
with the with the vice president kamala
harris maybe in the future that could
change if she does go back
from the great state of texas attorney
general ken paxton with me today in
focus thank you
thank you have a great day hi everyone
i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not gonna miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube
so subscribe right now